[Applause]
[Music]
Thailand is famous for tourism some of
the world's spiciest foods and also for
something you probably use every day but
didn't know that it was made there yes
we're talking about an essential part of
your computer something so important
that it makes Thailand a global news
story when things like this happen
Thailand's devastating floods are
hitting PC hard drive supplies more
analysts the Guardian 2011 this news
might be from 2011 but trust us things
haven't changed much Thailand is still a
huge production hub for electronics and
currently produces 40% of the world's
hard drives and that's surprising
because despite Thailand's growing
economy and great industrial
capabilities it's shockingly unstable
since the 1930s Thailand averages a coup
every four years it's a far cry from
democracy human rights are often
disrespected there's no freedom of
speech and insulting the monarchy can
land you in prison despite all of this
Thai people enjoy an income similar to
that of the Chinese there the
surprisingly egalitarian society with
virtually no unemployment and no
inflation
obviously they are not as rich as the
Swiss but they do much better than their
neighbors in Vietnam for example and no
in case you were wondering Thailand is
not oil rich or even gold rich nope this
is not a country that got rich on
natural resources at all that's why
today's question is how can such a
tumultuous and repressive country be
doing so well economically how did they
become such an important industrial
center well we're going to answer these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history in the country
of the blind Taiwan a key is very easy
to study because basically you just have
to remember one name and then keep
counting the current king is King Rama
the tenth but before that there was King
Rama the ninth
his father was a you guessed it Rama the
eighth since this goes all the way back
to the first Rama and I know what you're
probably thinking ten generations island
in you just say that Thailand was
unstable how can that be if they've had
the same family ruling for the last 237
years well I think that Eric is going to
give us a bit more information about
that so the reality is that since 1932
Thailand had 12 successful and seven
failed attempted cooze
most of these were coos from different
factions of the army fighting with one
another and always respecting the place
of the monarch so yes they changed the
government but not the King never the
king and the government always keeps his
classical Thai flavor of military
authoritarianism however a little brutal
authoritarianism that's never storm to
the bastions of democracy from cozying
up to a country you see Thailand's
growth and development in Southeast Asia
has been brought about thanks to Western
investment
[Music]
just think about the United States in
the 1970s they needed a partner in the
region and now take a look at this map
from the era here we have Cambodia which
was essentially a communist hellscape
Vietnam was also communist and at war
allow is landlocked ins again communist
Indonesia was unstable and problematic
and then there was Burma which remained
one of the world's most isolated
countries until very recently basically
there was only one country the US could
partner with and out Thailand it helped
a lot the kings of Thailand's and their
military leaders have always been
fervently anti-communist and so Thailand
became a great natural ally for the
United States and Japan during the Cold
War
[Music]
but we're not only talking about
politics when it comes to economics
Thailand has a shocking advantage that
most people are unaware of their
currency is surprisingly stable yes the
BART the Thai currency is one of the
world's most stable currencies it was
pegged to the dollar up until the 1970s
and this is a great advantage for
investors because no matter what happens
the money you put there will always hold
its value this is much better than what
many other countries can offer and then
there is the tourism by 1967 Thailand
already received over 330 thousand
tourists a year mostly from countries
like Japan Australia and the United
States in other words they could get
away with a dodgy political system
because all of its neighbors were more
than happy to spend their money and time
down and this explains the enormous
investments that the United States made
in this country for example they built
an entire highway measuring five hundred
and ten kilometers that became the first
step for the Thai government to start
building infrastructure of its own
[Music]
thanks to this the country now has some
of the best infrastructure networks in
the region but make no mistake Highlands
bestfriends was not America it was Japan
back then Japan was starting to develop
their own international agenda this is
when the flying geese paradigm came up
basically Japan wanted to increase its
economic clout in the region so the
Japanese government began investing
alongside the private sector in
Southeast Asian countries and again in
that time Thailand was the best place in
which to put your money in a way
Thailand was to Japan what Mexico was to
the United States I know you might be
thinking right now well this is another
story of a poor country rolling out the
red carpet for international capitalism
right well actually not really in fact
the opposite is true
at that time Thailand's was incredibly
protectionist during the 1970s some
goods such as alcohol shoes and cars had
tariffs of up to 90% and price controls
became commonplace and regular goods
Thailand's it was just a cheap labor but
then in the 1980s something happened
some things that had a deep impact on
this country
[Music]
a change
a hard-driven economy the first personal
computers were launched in the 1970s but
the real IT boom started in the 1980s
all of a sudden every office worker had
his or her own personal computer people
also bought one to have at home and
which countries led this technological
revolution well of course it was the
United States and Japan companies like
the us's Atari or Japanese sharp
dominated the PC market in the early
days but they were not the only ones
soon Apple would start creating their
own models too and the race it was on to
come up with better and cheaper models
they had to cut costs by any means and
there was one components that didn't
require the highly skilled labor that
you need for making microchips and that
component is the hard drive so which
country would be the best candidate to
develop hard drive manufacturing
facilities well that would be a country
that had close ties to one of the main
PC producers the country that already
had good industry and good
infrastructure and yes obviously that
country was Thailand
this explains why sigue technology one
of the leading hard drive firms opens
their first Factory in Thailand back in
[Music]
but this was not the only company to set
up shop there during the 1980s after a
couple more coup d'etat Thailand slashed
most of their tariffs they opened up
parts of their international trade and
this incentivized many other companies
to follow Seagate's need draw the
network effect we've talked about it a
few times here on visual politic once
you have a critical mass of companies
from a certain industry you create a
network of suppliers universities and
specialization for example by 1992
Hitachi started operating in Thailand
and now has 40 subsidiaries and 16,000
employees in the country this means that
they can buy all of the supplies they
need for making hard drives in Thailand
in bulk saving the company millions of
dollars CGI currently has over 11,000
workers in the country producing 50
million hard drives a year and half of
Toshiba star disk drives come from
Thailand Thailand is responsible for a
whopping 40% of the global hard disk
drive production that's worth about
twelve billion dollars
[Music]
and you might now be wondering well is
this a lot of money well it works out to
about 2.6 percent of Thailand's GDP yep
2.6 percent of pylons GDP comes from
only producing hard disk drives now no
one can say for certain where the trend
is heading but it certainly doesn't seem
to be slowing down
[Music]
Seagate to invest four hundred and
seventy million dollars in Thailand over
the next five years
Reuters 2015 but this isn't the only
good news for Thailand with an already
established network of technological
companies it's easy to attract other
industries to set up in the country in
the 1960s Thailand already had contracts
with some automobile firms now they are
the biggest competition in all of
Southeast Asia it's be she ships its
four millionth vehicle from Thailand
Bangkok Post 2019 in 2014 Japanese
companies employed 700,000 Thai workers
that's about one percent of the
population in 2012 Japanese corporations
invested 11 billion dollars in time out
but hold on a minute because it's not
all sunshine and smog tinged rainbows in
Thailand so here's the thing lots of
products probably products you use every
day are made in Thailand right but can
you name any of the Thai companies no we
can't really blame you everything you
own that says Made in Thailand on it
probably also has the brand of a
Japanese South Korean or US company and
active international mega corpse isn't
Thailand's only issue as a closer
[Music]
a nation at the crossroads rule is coos
I mentioned earlier well they're not
just to think the past in fact their
most recent guitar one of these
successful ones happened as recently as
May of 2014 when the hunter took over
they will did the usual authoritarian
fists in this case it led to a new
constitution being adopted in 2017 this
came after a referendum that had
received a 59% yes vote so it might
sound like the people got what they
wanted versed well not really the
military had intimidated threatened and
arrested critics of the referendum and
Constitution along with political
activists that advocated voting it down
or abstaining from voting altogether
even legal opposition parties were
formally forbidden from campaigning
against it the new constitution is
generally considered something that was
forced through by the military to
increase their influence and power for
decades to come and the same goes with
elections in March of 2019 actual
elections were held in Thailand the
issue
well.all 250 senators who helped decide
the prime minister were appointed by the
military and a military rule
as you can imagine the outcome Bozza
surprising as the ending of a romantic
comedy they elected general proud to
Changsha the man who launched the coup
and had run the country under the recent
hunter basically the military hunter
managed to manipulate elections to get
itself elected in order to maintain
control now there is a silver lining
though there was still civilian
parliamentary elections in which a large
legal and lively pro-democracy
opposition from a variety of parties
were voted in the most liberal of them
being the young future forward party
which got almost 18 percent of the votes
but unfortunately this has yet to
alleviate authoritarianism in the short
term and in the everyday running of the
country
[Music]
blasphemy laws are still enforced and an
insult on Facebook recently got a man
sentenced to 35 years in prison now
normally tumultuous coos into this sort
of arbitrary authoritarianism would
scare away investors and to tie
governments that were aware of this
however the Thai people are lucky in at
least two regards external factors are
keeping the Thai economy afloat and
their government knows how to capitalize
on it Thailand dangles 50% tax cut from
manufacturers fleeing China exactly the
trade war between China and the United
States has a lot of losers but also some
winners and Thailand could be one of
them as companies flee US tariffs on
China they look to set up shop in other
countries with similarly cheaper labor
Thailand's is one of those places these
conditions mixed with a lot of
experience attracting international
business with things like tax cards mean
that Thailand's will at very least
maintain its foreign investment on the
plus side who's another booming industry
in this country tourism
so how many tourists came to Thailand in
1967 is 330,000 now today it's over
thirty million tourists every year if
you thought that Thailand was overly
reliant and hard disk drives 2.6 percent
of GDP well keep in mind that tourism
makes up about 70% of GDP it doesn't
look like it's going down anytime soon
either
however Thailand is still just a bit
player on a global scale Thailand's
essentially an industrial park and a
tourist play grounds for more
influential Western and oriental
countries one that subjects to the
occasional storm of power struggles
Thailand is still stuck in a cycle of
Coos that keep Thailand from
experiencing being one of the miracles
like Singapore Japan Thailand lacks its
own entrepeneurs and international
corporations that would keep all of the
profits in the country and this is the
price that you pay for having such an
authoritarian and more to the point
arbitrary system if you want to have
your own entrepreneurs you need a higher
degree of freedom and stability
well now it's over to you do you think
Thailand will climb out of the middle
income trap and become a South Korea in
the jungle will the future forward party
succeed in cementing a democracy in the
country or well things just remain the
same what we'd love to hear your
comments below.also please do visit our
friends from reconsider Mediacom they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also we publish brand new
videos every week so please do subscribe
hit that Bell button give this video a
thumbs up if you liked it and as always
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and here
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there